BUT WAS ALSO USED BY HAMAS AS
THE FAR LEFT THREATENS PRESIDENT
BIDEN TO CUT TIES WITH OUR KEY
ALLY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE,
CONGRESSWOMAN.
SO FAR AT LEAST JOE BIDEN SAYS
THAT ISRAEL SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
DEFEND ITSELF AS NECESSARY.
THERE ARE MIXED SIGNALS AMONG
DEMOCRATS.
HOW WOULD YOU ENGAGE THE
AMERICAN RESPONSE SO FAR TO WHAT
ISRAEL NEEDS TO DO?
>> ISRAEL HAS BEEN A LONG ALLY
OF THE UNITED STATES AND WE HAVE
MADE COMMITMENTS TO DEFEND
ISRAEL AND ISRAEL HAS THE RIGHT
TO DEFEND ITSELF AGAINST THE
ROCKETS FIRED BY HAMAS TARGETING
CIVILIANS.
WE HAVE TO STAND STRONG, AND
STAND WITH ISRAEL AND THEY ARE
DOING THE RIGHT THING DEFENDING
THEMSELVES AND PROTECTING THEIR
CIVILIANS.
PETE: YET, CONGRESSWOMAN, WE’RE
SEEING ON THE 17th YEAR FOR
A FOUR YEAR TERM FOR ABBAS IN
THE PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY.
PART OF THE REASON THE ELECTIONS
DIDN’T HAPPEN THE FEAR HAMAS
WOULD TAKE OVER.
YET THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
SENDING MORE MONEY TO THE
PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY WHEN THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION CUT IT
OFF.
SO AREN’T WE MAKING ISRAEL’S JOB
MORE DIFFICULT?
>> WELL, BIDEN ADMINISTRATION’S
POLICY IS, YOU KNOW DEFINITELY
EMBOLDENING THE ATTACKERS, THE
HAMAS.
WE NEED TO SEND A STRONG MESSAGE
DEFINITELY, I MEAN SEND A VERY,
VERY STRONG MESSAGE THAT THE
UNITED STATES WILL STAND WITH
ISRAEL AND SUPPORT ISRAEL’S
ACTIONS.
PETE: ABSOLUTELY.
THAT MESSAGE SHOULD BE LOUD AND
CLEAR AS IT WAS UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
CONGRESSWOMAN YOU RECENTLY TOOK
A TRIP TO THE BORDER AS WELL.
THIS ADMINISTRATION NOT WILLING
TO CALL IT A CRISIS, OF COURSE
THE HUMAN COST IS EVIDENT AS IS
THE PHYSICAL COST OF DRUGS AND
TRAFFICKING.
WE ACTUALLY HAD GREG ABBOTT, THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS ON OUR SHOW
EARLIER, LATER THIS WEEK, EXCUSE
ME EARLIER IN THE WEEK.
THIS IS WHAT HE HAD TO SAY,
LISTEN.
>> THERE IS DANGEROUS DRUGS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
WE OBTAINED ENOUGH FENTANYL
ACROSS THE BORDER TO KILL EVERY
SINGLE PERSON IN THE STATE OF
NEW YORK.
SO THIS IS A VERY DEADLY
SITUATION HAPPENING ON THE
BORDER.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BETTER
WAKE UP.
PETE: HUMAN TRAFFICKING PROBLEM,
A DRUG CRISIS AND YOU’VE SEEN IT
AS WELL.
>> YES, I HAVE GONE DOWN TO THE
BORDER IN TEXAS, THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
I ALSO WENT DOWN TO THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER.
WHAT I HAVE SEEN DEFINITELY THE
SECURITY CRISIS, HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
WE HAVE A CRISIS AT THE BORDER,
YET THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
REFUSES TO SEE IT FOR WHAT IT
IS.
I URGED THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
AND ALSO VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS TO GET DOWN TO THE BORDER
TO SEE FOR THEMSELVES, MAYBE
THEY CHANGE THEIR MIND.
DRUG CARTELS ARE THE ONLY ONES
BENEFITING FROM THIS BORDER
CRISIS.
IT IS HURTING AMERICANS.
IT IS UNDERMINING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
IT IS TRADING THE RESOURCE FROM
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS, CPB
AGENTS, WHEN THEY SHOULD BE
PATROLLING THE BORDERS.
RIGHT NOW ALL OF THE ILLEGAL
ACTIVITIES ARE SLIPPING THROUGH
BECAUSE OUR BORDER PATROL AGENTS
ARE NOW SERVING THE ROLE OF
CARETAKERS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION REFUSES TO SEE.
I REALLY ENCOURAGE THEM TO GET
DOWN THERE, GET YOUR BUTTS OUT
THERE AND SEE IT FOR YOURSELVES
WHAT I’M SEEING.
IT IS BREAKING MY HEART.
I SEE SO MANY MOTHERS WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN BECAUSE THEY ARE
GETTING A MIXED SIGNAL WHEN YOU
COME ACROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY, UP WITH WAY OR
ANOTHER YOU WILL BE TAKEN CARE
OF.
WRONG, WRONG.
WE NEED TO REINSTATE THE
POLICIES THAT HAVE WORKED DURING
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION AND
REALLY, I REALLY ENCOURAGE THEM
TO GET DOWN THERE AND LET’S FIX
THE PROBLEM.
PETE: I WISH THEY WANTED TO SEE
IT.
FEELS LIKE WILLFUL BLINDNESS AT
THIS POINT.
I LOVE WHAT YOU SAID.
IT UNDERMINES LEGAL IMMIGRATION
WHICH IS WHAT WE WANT.
WHEN YOU DISINCENTIVIZE IT YOU
GET A WHOLE DIFFERENT TYPE OF